the winner of the European Union's
Sakharov Prize which honours people who
defend human rights and freedoms has
been awarded to Ilham tohti Tati is an
economist and a member of China's Weger
community he has worked for more than 20
years to improve the rights of the
minority ethnic group he is currently
serving a life sentence in prison in
China the prize is worth of fifty
thousand euros it was first handed out
30 years ago and for more on the story
we can speak to Joe Hara l homme the
daughter of Ilham tohti she joins us
from Washington DC Joe hare thank you
for being with us here on DW what does
this prize mean to you and your family
hello
first of all means a lot to the earlier
community to my family in to me this is
considered like safety list for my
family I would say I would hope I hope
this prize this award could help my
father be away from some potential harm
from the Chinese government and I hope
when the Chinese government is when they
decide to take a negative a negative
action towards my father they would
consider the international attention and
also this is a I would say this is a
recognition for my father's work for the
past decades and also this is a
recognition recognition for the of the
plight of the Uighurs of their current
situation Jenner tell us more about your
father and why his work has been so
important to this community it's not a
recent issue it's been a while since the
leaguers have been suffering from the
Chinese government's regime such as non
fare education opportunities no fair job
opportunities and no access of free
religion to free freedom to practice our
religion and my father has been true I
had tried so hard
to talk to the Chinese government and
also trying to promote peace in between
Han Chinese group and the Uighurs in
order to fix those issues he was one of
the very few people who were able to
speak up for the Uighurs since there
were no freedom of speech and speak of
freedom of thoughts in China and it was
very difficult for someone like my
father who could actually decide to
speak up and continue his work for so
many years and even though he knew he
this his action could get him into
trouble could get him and get him
arrested but he continued his work and
he sacrifice himself now he is serving a
life sentence enjoy her you mentioned
that you hoped the international
attention might in a way protect your
father you haven't had any contact with
him for years now how worried are you
about him and other family members in
China so the last time I saw my father
was 2013 February 2nd but the last the
last time our family members heard about
my father it was 2017 that was also when
the concentration camp started our
family members were are no longer able
to visit him and we don't know if he
still had held in the same prison room
if we we don't even know he's still
alive and we don't know how he's doing
and my family members of course I'm
worried about worried about them every
single day my brothers are still very
young today is actually my brother's
birthday tomorrow's my father's birthday
and I hope this award can be a sort of a
birthday gift for for both of them and
most of the people say happy birthday
but I would say I wish both of them long
and healthy life that's the most I wish
for for them both of them now Joe Harry
you yourself have been such a vocal
advocate for the weaker community what
do you think needs to happen at this
point to improve the situation of
weekers in China also looking to the
international community first of all I
would urge the US has been doing a lot
and with this awards given by the
European Parliament's also
gesture from the I would say it's a
gesture from the European Parliament for
the Uighurs cause and I would hope this
award and could bring up more countries
to stand up for the Uighurs cause and
also I would wish them to stand up to
ask the trans government to release my
father other intellectuals who are
serving I'm just unjust unjustice in in
the prison or locked up in the
concentration camp okay Joe hair Elohim
the daughter of Ilham tohti thank you so
much for joining us here and DW thank
you